hello in this video I will talk about
thyroid hormone synthesis into
regulation and the mechanism of action
at a molecular level so nearer on the
neck we have a butterfly-shaped small
gland known as thyroid gland the thyroid
gland is situated just below the highway
born on the on on the track here and the
thyroid gland is kind of joined with
each other by a region known as
Eastham us if we take a cross-section of
the thyroid gland we would see that
inside the thyroid gland there are
several follicles known as thyroid
follicles and thus polical are are
formed off for refigure cells inside the
Fontan there are colloidal substances
known as colloid and the thyroid hop
carried and gets his blood supply from
superior and inferior thyroid artery and
there are other connective tissue
connecting all these thyroid follicles
now first we would ask that how Tyrod
hormone is synthesized at a molecular
level so tyroid hormone synthesis
requires iodine and the iodine is
supplied from blood so from the blood
iodine is getting inside the thyroid
follicular cell by a secondary active
transport and this secondary active
transport allows ideal to get inside the
thyroid follicular cell along with
sodium now inside the thyroid follicular
cell the ironing is converted into a
elementary form of iodine by the active
and by the activity of the enzyme
thyroperoxidase now the in the placement
of the genome of the thyroid the thyroid
follicular cell would produce something
called the thyroid globulin or the
thyroglobulin
so it's a scaffold on which the
synthesis of thyroid hormones would be
done so it's very important now inside
the thyroid follicular cell and on the
thyroid globulin there are several type
of modification
especially hibernation is happening so
Hardy is attached on these thyroglobulin
which consists several more several
molecules of tyrosine connected to each
other by this globular now our beam is
attached to the tight divergence and
form either mono Hydra tyrosine or 3/5
TI o tyrosine or di T also this mono
Hydra tyrosine and diatou tyrosine can
fuse together to form a try I do tyranny
or t3 or bi t di D can combine with each
other to form they try with hybrid rule
or t4 so t3 and t4 are the key hormones
secreted by the thyroid gland now what
happens is after production of t3 and t4
it is secreted into the colloid and
there it is stored and waiting for a
signal to tell to release the t3 and t4
and we would look at what the signal
means but in brief the signal comes from
the anterior pituitary known as thyroid
stimulating hormone so when the thyroid
stimulating hormone comes these these
thyroid globulin are actually cleaved
and it is secreted into the blood and
from the blood stream it can go to the
target organs since we have talked about
how the thyroid hormone is produced now
we should think about how to tie rod
hormone production and secretion is
regulated so thyroid hormone regulation
requires hypothalamus and the pituitary
so just on the brain stem there is a
region known as hypothalamus syndrome
and from the hypothalamus there is a
gland which is what rooting out is known
as pituitary and also we have our
thyroid gland at the base of the hyoid
bone and on the trachea so the most
important hormone released by the
hypothalamus
is known as thyroid releasing hormone or
CRH and then abs on into Italy and belly
to secrete TSH or thyroid stimulating
hormone TSH acts upon the thyroid gland
and make them to secrete t3 and t4 which
are key thyroid hormones t3 and t4 has
widespread role on heart muscle liver
and overall t3 and t4
is very important and controls various
aspects of metabolism now important to
note that there is a negative feedback
regulation controlling the thyroid
secretion so when it is too much lemon
of t3 and t4 it tells the hypothalamus
to release let's come out of trh and
thereby secretion of t3 and t4 and
production of the 3 T and T 4 could be
shaped now thyroid hormone has
widespread rule on heart for example on
the heart muscle it increases the number
of beta adrenergic receptor it also
enhances the response of catecholamines
also it increases the proportion of
alpha - a heavy chain on the
cardiomyocytes now mean that adipose
tissue it works in a catabolic fashion
and it exerts a catabolic effect so it
helps in degradation of the fat into
fatty acids so in one word it helps in
lipolysis also in case of the muscles it
break down protein into peptides it
overall increases the metabolic rate of
the body also thyroid hormone is known
to increase the production of LDL
receptors and thereby regulating lipid
metabolism especially the lipoprotein
metabolism
apart from that thyroid hormone
exerts many other functions and also
help in redeeming a production so there
are wide variety of rule in fiber by
regulated by the thyroid
now let us quickly look at at a
molecular level how Tyrone exerts its
function Tyrell hormone is known to
activate genes so tyroid hormone binds
to its specific receptor or thyroid
receptor which is present at the nucleus
so thyroid hormone receptors are the
nuclear receptors thyroid hormone
receptors bind to its core receptor in
the nucleus itself and activate specific
genes which exerts its cellular and
physiological effect on specific organs
now thyroid hormone is bound to this
thyroid receptor thyroid receptor is
basically a sim finger motif containing
transcription factor so it would
interact with other co-activators and
colon present to regulate gene
expression and it binds to specific
region of the team known as thyroid
response element to exert its function
so that that was all about how how
thyroid hormone is produced regulated
and synthesized so if you like mine for
you give it a quick thumbs up and don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you